l'armée française les forces françaises de
l'antre devaient et doivent s'assurer de
la maîtrise du terrain cela a été fait
et enfin à moins d'un effondrement il
fallait il faut en dépit des explications à la
désobéissance et à la diversion prodigués par
10 des voiliers notre armée doit rester
y reste maintenue dans le devoir elle a
été elle l'est honoraires maintenant
on peut construire nous sommes prêts
a établi un accord avec les
dirigeants de la rébellion
pour ramener décidément la paix en algérie pour
régler les conditions de l'autodétermination
pour définir les éléments d'une coopération
franco algérienne le général a exprimé son
désir de voir les éléments représentatifs en
algérie entreprendre eux mêmes la préparation
du référendum nous sommes décidés à organiser
dès à présent une force publique algérienne
dont disposera le pouvoir provisoire quand
il assumera la responsabilité de conduire
le pays à la décision enfin le président
de la république après avoir condamné les
anciens jeux des partis politiques a
conclu pour la france qui traverse un
passage dure et dangereuse le salut est
le succès exige la cohésion nationale
avec beaucoup de solennité la suède a rendu un
dernier hommage à celui qu'elle considère comme
l'un de ces grands hommes monsieur d'agde
à marchal dans la cathédrale d'uppsala le
service funèbre avait réuni la famille royale et
le gouvernement au grand complet la suède avait
tenu à faire des funérailles nationales
au second secrétaire général de l'onu
paris a pavoisé aux couleurs nigérienne
en l'honneur de monsieur diori hamani
président de la république du
niger que le général de gaulle
accueilli à l'elysée où premières
heures d'une visite de trois jours
à
pour en même temps que l'un des leaders
du monde africains d'expression française
c'est aussi un ami que la france a reçus
et c'est d'abord cette amitié que monsieur
diori hamani a voulu célébrer en allant se
recueillir sur la tombe du soldat inconnu
n'avait-il pas déclaré dès son
arrivée en france mon pays tout
entier participe à la cordialité
et à la chaleur de votre accueil
après la journée des casseroles et celle
des oriflammes alger devait connaître
la journée des embouteillages
l'opération proprement dite à
part quelques points centraux s'est révélé
être un demi échec aux consignes de l'oas
la journée ne s'est pourtant pas achevé sans
incident les pierres et des bouteilles ont volé
les auto pompes sont entrés en action
ainsi que les grenades lacrymogènes
pendant plusieurs heures un groupe de
jeunes européens et les gendarmes mobiles se
sont ainsi opposés sans aménité images dans
alger fiévreux images d'un alger où il faut
peu de choses pour déclencher la violence
a bizerte c'est la détente une détente
actifs pourrait-on dire puisqu'elle
s'est traduite par l'enlèvement des
barbelés qui marquait les positions
avancées dans la ville moderne
l'humour même n'a pas manqué
parachutistes français d'un côté
soldats tunisiens de l'autre ont
fait place nette des barrières qui les séparaient
ainsi s'est matérialisé le geste de
bonne volonté de la france dont les
troupes vont regagner les positions
qui étaient les leurs avant la grave
crise du mois de juillet première
étape d'un règlement d'ensemble
à brest monsieur messmer ministre des armées a
présidé à la mise à l'eau d'un navire inédit en
france la résolue et le premier porte hélicoptère
de la marine nationale dans trois ans le bâtiment
qui jauge 11000 tonnes prendra la relève
du croiseur école jeanne d'arc qui après
vingt-trois croisière et 30 ans de bons et loyaux
services a sans doute bien mérité sa retraite
hollande un nouveau bateau de sauvetage a vu le
jour regard tranquille mine assurée son inventaire
a tenu un enfer lui même la démonstration
faisant preuve d'une confiance parfaite dans
son oeuvre il s'agissait tout de même de se faire
précipiter à l'eau de 9 m enfermer dans le bateau
au demeurant le résultat fut
des plus concluants résistants
insubmersible l'engin quoi qu'on
fasse retombe toujours sur ses acquis
voilà un inventeur qui peut
regarder le monde en face
avant de s'ouvrir le salon de l'auto
n'avait déjà plus de secret celle dont
on dit qu'elle n'est grande qu'à l'intérieur
la simca 1000 avait déjà livré les siens son
habitabilité son coffre à l'avant et
son moteur de 5 chevaux à l'arrière
bien suspendu stable la simca 1000 et
une arme efficace que la firme de voix
silence dans la grande bataille des
petites cylindrées engagé cette année
larmes de renault c'est la r4 qui succède à la 4
chevaux et qui a elle aussi déjà livré ses secrets
on ne s'étonnera pas de rencontrer la r4 dans les
chemins de terre voire en plein champ rustique
cette voiture qui adopte délibérément la formule
du moteur à l'avant possède une soute à bagages
spacieuse mais aussi une suspension qui permet une
utilisation tout terrain padoue pas d'antigènes
pas de graissage il lui suffit d'un peu de sens
qu'en mai avec cela un rayon de braquage qui
autorise les manoeuvres les plus audacieuses
mais les performances des voitures modernes
exige des industries d'équipements de plus en plus
perfectionnés ainsi est né le complexe industriel
damien dunlop a édifié ici la première usine
d'europe et l'une des plus modernes du monde
c'est l'univers du robot l'automation poussé
à un niveau très élevé se traduit par une
production de 8000 points par jour
l'équipement de 16 cents voitures une
réalisation qui se veut à la mesure du marché
commun un autre effet de ce marché commun et
de l'abaissement des barrières douanières
aura été de faire passer la frontière à la
production française de poids lourds c'est
ainsi que les camion berliet ont pris une
place significative sur un marché qui connaît
bien le problème du matériel lourd l'allemagne
la naturalisation et maintenant tu automatique
et l'habillage définitif des châssis s'effectue
sur place selon les besoins des acheteurs paris
ne verra pas cette année s'ouvrir de salon du
poids lourd mais on peut dire que ce salon se
tient sur toutes les routes du marché commun
le vent d'automne il fallait s'y attendre a
soufflé sur les coiffures pour les matinées
déjà fraîche elles ont pris sept lignes
asymétriques que jacques du tour a créé
avec sciences po ils nous proposent une
coiffure gonflée orné d'une légère frange
est prise dans un bandeau pour l'après midi
voici minou d'antoine salvador envolée sur
le front léger mouvement tombant sur les
yeux pour le cocktail il a imaginé une
coiffure plus osés déportés de gauche
à droite très travaillé sur la nuque
pour le soir bien sûr toutes les audaces sont
permises et les ornements briegel jean clément
a choisi tante olga même et en os le vison blanc
qui sied aux cheveux blonds de nuit moscovite
pour les grands soirs enfin rien n'empêche
de rêver d'une coiffure vraiment éclatant
des dizaines de milliers de parisiens haletant à
6,7 à longchamp au départ du grand prix de l'arc
de triomphe sous les sabots du vainqueur il y
à 200 millions lui n'en sommes pas encore là
tous les chevaux ont une chance le poulain de sa
winston churchill à la hâte en le mors aux dents
dès les premières foulées c'est très crade mais un
peu présomptueux pour l'anecdote on voudrait bien
qu'il gagne cependant c'est compter sans me lever
tôt le fils à papa ap ap le crack italien ribot a
déjà gagné deux fois le prix de l'arc de triomphe
alors pourquoi pas moi dix mots le vélo et
joignant le geste à la parole maul vdo prouve s'il
en était besoin que bon sang ne saurait mentir
comme papa il a triomphé de tous les
cracks européen avec une parfaite maîtrise
cette année le salon de l'auto a ouvert ses
portes sur l'horaire car on y viendra rêver
de la voiture la plus chère 40 millions de
la meilleure marché de la plus rapide de la
voiture des voix ou simplement de la voiture
de grand luxe et puis on regardera de plus
près les voitures pour lesquelles finalement on
n'est plus celle dont on appréciera la réalité
quotidienne chez part on retrouvera par le
jeu du tournoi broche les 2 pl 17 la berline
et le cabriolet tic avec roger rivière qui
songe à remplacer des courses cyclistes par
les courses automobiles on y appréciera la
ceinture de sécurité qui peut être adaptée
et le siège inclinable jusqu'à
la position couchette qui est la
caractéristique principale de l'équipement
relaxe maximum rechercher cette année
vedette du complexe industriel simca dont elle
est la dernière née la simca 1000 cinq chevaux
nerveuse confortable spacieuse ne fera pourtant
pas oublié la robuste étoiles six chevaux
ni l'as monaco une voiture
à toit véritablement ouvrant
elle ne faut pas oublier non plus
et autres aînés l'étoile super ou
la confortable routière que s'est
révélé être l'ariane sept chevaux
chez peugeot on retrouvera la gamme des 404
et des 403 à moteur essence ou diesel cette
gamme s'est enrichie cette année d'un
nouveau modèle ou plutôt d'un modèle
de luxe le moteur à injection indirecte qui
développe 85 chevaux équipe cette nouvelle
venue le cabriolet 400 cas c'est là une
innovation dans la construction française
le salon 61 un des meilleur de l'après guerre
la rupture entre damas et le caire est aujourd'hui
consommé dans les rues de la capitale syrienne la
foule a applaudi au coup de force qui a mis fin
à l'union scellée en 58 avec l'egypte et qui fut
provoquée par la volte face du colonel
serrage ancien vice président de l'aéro
quant à l'armée syrienne dont le nouveau
commandant en chef le général zahreddine
s'est fait le porte parole elle a laissé
un monsieur cous baril le soin de former
un gouvernement civil et tandis que
les tanks montait encore la garde
dans certains quartiers de damas c'est l
exode général des égyptiens vers le liban
fonctionnaire aux militaires ils
sont aujourd'hui indésirable en syrie
mais il n'avait pas oublié dans leurs
bagages le portrait du colonel nasser
atmosphère de fête à yaoundé pour les cérémonies
de la réunification monsieur amadou ahidjo
président de la république camerounaise qui
devient président fédéral a assisté au défilé
qui a marqué l'aboutissement du voeu émis par
le cameroun méridional précédemment sous mandat
britannique d'être rattachée à la république
camerounaise à laquelle la france avait accordé
l'indépendance en 1960 après la revue militaire
un défilé résumant les activités économiques
sociales et sportives d'une nouvelle étape se
déroulait au milieu de l'allégresse générale
la première phase des contacts est
ouest sur berlin s'est achevée par
la visite que monsieur grand mikko a fait au
président kennedy visite intéressante dit on
à washington utile dit on à moscou ce qui ne
veut pas dire qu'un pas important était effet
à pékin la chine populaire a célébré
son douzième anniversaire célébration
maintenant classique qui fait défiler sur la place
de la paix céleste de temps à autre
c'est tung un demi million de chinois
le défilé qui comporte des danseurs des
miliciens des paysans des communes rurales
des acrobates des membres des minorités
nationales des enfants s'apparente à un
long cortège de carnaval il
a duré deux heures d'horloge
avec le roi du népal la reine-mère de belgique a
assisté sans nul doute au spectacle
le plus impressionnant de l'année
dans un monde où s'impose la technique
l'équilibré physique des travailleurs
est une nécessité premier l'alcool
représente un danger pour leur sécurité
nous avons demandé à monsieur texier président
de l'institut national de sécurité si en 1961
l'alcool avait une responsabilité importante
dans les accidents du travail l'abus d'alcool
amenuisant les réflexes on va un accroissement
des risques d' enquête approfondie menée avec le
concours du corps médical il ressort que l'alcool
est responsable de 10 % des accidents légers
du travail et de 15 % des accidents graves
il importe avant tout que les travailleurs
puissent trouver sur place des boissons servies
c'est ce but que vise plus particulièrement les
textes officiels du mois d'août dernier fixant
les conditions dans lesquelles les boissons non
alcoolisées doivent être mises à la disposition
des travailleurs des expériences antérieures
ont prouvé que dans les établissements où
des boissons non alcoolisées été mise à la
disposition des travailleurs l'alcoolisme et les
accidents consécutifs et peut-être en régulation
depuis ce temps twister traduisez tordons tordez
m'étendre quoi dire et bleu eh bien regardez
nouvelle danse à la mode le twist après
saint tropez a bien entendu envahi tous
les clubs parisiens que ce soit le club saint
germain où les nouveaux venus comme là dedans
m
mais plus qu'une danse il faut voir
dans le twist un rythme et un rythme
séduisant puisqu'ils s'expriment sans
bouger les pieds on ne s'étonnera donc
pas de le voir un jour prochain envahir notre vie
il y a
mais les cours du soir sont
déjà pleins de balancer de 1
à 4 en avant et de 5 à 8 en arrière
et caen 1 2 3 4 5 et qu'on a bien
m
m ainsi naît comme chez georges et rosie toute
une génération de twister n'échappe pas qui
veut aux épidémies si nous voulons rester dans
le vin il nous faudra aussi savoir plus tu es
et plus hautes personnalités de la république
française ont salué à l'elysée l'impératrice
et le shah d'iran hôte du général et de madame
de gaulle vous est pour la france un ami avait
dit le chef de l'état français en accueillant
le matin même le souverain d'iran en l'honneur
des invités de la france il donnait au soir de
cette première journée un grand dîner 298 couvert
oui
mais paris réservé à l'impératrice farah qui était
il n'y a pas si longtemps simplement l'étudiante
farabi bas un autre rendez vous celui de la mode
elle a pu admirer avec la princesse chanas fille
du che à une sélection des créations de 22 grands
couturiers parisiens une quintessence de la motte
m la rentrée universitaire est commencé
pour loger les effectifs estudiantins 268
mille élèves de l'enseignement supérieur
deux cent mille mètres carrés de locaux
nouveaux ont été construits et 5000
étudiants trouveront place dans les
nouveaux bâtiments de la faculté des sciences
édifié au dessus de la vieille halle aux vins
de conception très moderne doté de
salles de travaux nombreuses et de
laboratoires parfaitement outillé ses huit
amphithéâtres spacieux lui permettent de
décongestionner les anciens établissements
d agrandissement prévu lui permettront
d'accueillir dix neuf mille étudiants
un bel effort et qui doit se poursuivre
formose célébré avec éclat sous la présidence
de chiang kai shek le 50e anniversaire de la
révolution qui me fait en 1911 au règne de
la dynastie mandchoue et en un temps à 4000
ans de régime monarchique en chine un défilé
militaire à marquer à taipei cette commémoration
onze mille hommes de toutes les armes les fusées
antiaériennes des organisations paramilitaires
féminine participaient à cette manifestation
en même temps que 1000 véhicules et près de
200 avions à réaction cette commémoration
était placée sous le signe du double 10 qui
représente le 10 octobre date de la naissance de
sun yat sen fondateur de la république chinoise
un mille hommes en oeuvre sous
le regard du président kennedy
c'est peu sans doute en comparaison des
quatre cent mille soldats qui manoeuvre
sous pavillon soviétique en allemagne de l'est
mais ces exercices d'ensemble n'ont été
que le prélude à la gigantesque opération
bouclier du ciel qui devait mettre en jeu
la totalité des forces aériennes américaines
du côté des russes deux parachutistes
ont accompli une double performance
sauté en chute libre et ce film est mutuellement
wes acrobatique oui mais également prouvé ce
technique avec la réussite d'un pareil travelling
de force technique sans doute mais les techniques
modernes nous ont habitués à de semblables tour
de force c'est par son contexte surtout
que l'immersion d'un oléoduc de 86 cm de
diamètre à travers d'isère mérite d'être mentionné
jusqu'ici en effet le pétrole qu'ils viennent du
moyen-orient ou d'afrique devait emprunter
l'atlantique pour gagner l'europe du nord
la construction du pipeline sud européen ouvre
désormais au pétrole une route directe qui court
circuite le long chemin traditionnel des tanks
est avec le pipeline dont la pose se poursuit
au long de la vallée du rhône et qui reliera
marseille à karlsruhe le pétrole brut n'aura
plus que 750 km à parcourir au lieu de 4500
que doivent couvrir les cargos le pipeline
pour à véhiculer 15 millions de tonnes de pétrole
par an soit la charge de 300 groupes bancaires
face sur mer pendant ce temps voit
pousser les énormes réservoirs du
futur parc de stockage sur 150 hectares
s'élève d'immenses cuves qui pourront en à
gazinet plus d'un million de mètres cubes soit
la capacité de 24 pétrolier de 50 mille tonnes
la verra le port pétrolier de marseille
ou s'alimentait seule jusqu'ici la région
marseillaise se voit de ce fait promu au
rang de grand port pétrolier de l'europe
mais déjà la verra et marseille doivent
compter avec un rival le port italien de
gênes car le pipeline qui se construit
en france à un concurrent le pipeline
auquel l'italie veut faire franchir
les alpes vers cette même allemagne
les premiers éléments du pipeline
italiens ont d'ores et déjà été
posée il n'y aura pas un mais
deux pipelines pour l'europe
et l'ambition de marseille se heurte
aujourd'hui à gênes qui a refait ses
quais et agrandit son port et
c'est ainsi qu'entre les deux
ports méditerranéens comme entre les deux
pipelines la guerre est aujourd'hui déclaré
peu elles sont dix
elles sont dix dont l'âge oscille entre 65
et 80 ans guy bonne grand-mère de paris que
leur 707 en 707 à elles toutes n'ont
pas fait renoncer aux divertissements
du maquillage et du déguisement aux
joies de ce théâtre sans malice qui
évoque une chorale et puis quand on chante
n'est ce pas c'est qu'on a toujours 20 ans
i
il
et
non
il ça
elle va bien et
oui
c'est
à et oh
al ahly
soufflant à plus de 350 km à l'heure
des vagues déchaînées déferlant sur
les habitations c'est le 18e qui font
que l'archipel japonais et essuyer
cette année 650 mille personnes
en cuir souffrir de ces violences
le bilan compte parmi les plus désastreux
qu'on est enregistrée 175 morts 20 disparus
3000 blessés et 74 mille habitations
écrasé ou emportées par les flots en furie
dont revoir s'enflammer en belgique le
vieil antagonisme entre wallons et flamands
63000 flamands ont défilé dans les rues de la
capitale belge aux cris de bruxelles flamand
slogan auquel les fédéralistes wallon répondu
par d'autres slogans bousculent à des bagarres
ont finalement émaillé cette manifestation qui
avait débuté dans l'indifférence des bruxellois
et dont le but était double dans l'esprit de ses
protagonistes affirmer les droits des flamands sur
bruxelles et réclamer la fixation définitive de la
frontière linguistique entre wallons et flamands
quatre blessés en définitive et 10
arrestations mais bruxelles à la fière
plusieurs nuits durant les forces de police
sont restées en état d' alerte à paris à la
suite des manifestations auxquelles avaient
pris par vingt mille musulmans algériens à
ménilmontant comme la goutte d'or le rideau de fer
étaient tirés devant les boutiques et les cinémas
journée de manifestations
silencieuses la grève des
commerçants algériens assez généralement suivies
dépit du dispositif de surveillance
de la police les musulmans algériens
n'avaient pas renoncé à continuer leurs
manifestations mais cette fois ce furent
des groupes de femmes et d'enfants
qui tentèrent de se former groupe
qui devait être rapidement canaliser vers les
centres sociaux de la préfecture de la seine
en tout un millier de femmes peuvent ainsi
appréhender pour être reconduite chez elle
tous les manifestants arrêtaient le premier soit
il y en eut 11500 ne devait pas connaître le même
sort 15 cents en effet ont été refoulés vers
l'algérie dans leurs douars d'origine c'est
ainsi qu'à orly cent quarante quatre d'entre eux
ont été embarqués à destination de constantine
à tunis où il a été l'hôte du président bourguiba
le président de la république du sénégal monsieur
léopold sédar senghor a sans doute beaucoup
parler de l'algérie il a eu notamment au cours
de son séjour avec les responsables du fln
des entretiens qu'il a qualifié de fructueux
et continuant son voyage par paris il est
allé à l'elysée confié au général de gaulle
ses impressions sur la nouvelle équipe
du gpr à qu'ils déclaraient avoir trouvé
assez positive est disposé à négocier
toutefois le président senghor s'est
nettement défendu de vouloir assurer les
bons offices entre la france et le fln
moscou dans la nouvelle salle du kremlin
monsieur khrouchtchev a ouvert le 22ème
congrès du parti communiste soviétique
il l'a ouvert par un premier discours de
six heures juste derrière lui le maréchal
vorochilov ci est entendue désigné comme
l'un des instigateurs du complot anti parts
l'albanie quant à elle a subi également les
foudres de nos cieux cas qu'il l'a accusé de
déviationnisme ce que la chine en monsieur
chou et là il n'a ni apprécié ni applaudi
parmi les autres chapitres recherche avec
l'ouest d'une solution concrète et annonce
d'une explosion nucléaire de 50 mégatonnes
la vie moderne que de simplification ne
lui doit-on pas c'est par exemple cette
sphère de 9 grammes qui va remplacer les lots
chariots des machines à écrire et permettre le
changement instantanée des caractères c'est
aussi l'ingénieux système qui permettra aux
automobilistes qu'ils trouveront leur route et
gonflé de sortir de leur ennui branché l'autre
extrémité du tuyau à la valve d'une
roue normalement gonflés et attendre
calmement que les changes gazeux se soit fait
simple direz vous encore fallait-il y pense
l'art de ses ventes et à la mode
orientale a fait lui aussi de
sérieux progrès depuis qu'on a adopté la
technique du batteur de carpète à moteur
enfin d'amérique nous bien l'image donc
tous les hommes ont rêvé depuis ici car
l'homme volant du moins le solde
à volants puisque c'est l'armée
américaine qui a expérimenté la nouvelle
ceinture fusée avec succès comme on voit
poésie pas mort tu disais un télégramme célèbres
tel pourrait être aussi la justification de cette
exposition consacrée aux activités de quelques
personnages particulièrement inspiré de monsieur
marc mains des essarts en vendée par exemple qui
ne se contente pas d'être simplement le jardinier
horticulteurs qui est née transforme à coups de
sécateurs son jardin en un univers avicole qui
ne manque pas de féerie dans sa villa au bord
de la nationale 7 près dé san monsieur cérons
lui autre inspiré manille le fil de fer et
le ciment ainsi perfectionne t-il d'année en
année un autre univers singulier d'animaux et
de personnages chez qui la légende le dispute
à l'histoire perd la victoire compris avis à
la postérité cet artiste modeste prend soin
d'enfermer dans chacune de ses oeuvres
sa carte de visite et le journal du jour
mais le plus inspiré et certainement
monsieur isidore gardien de cimetière près
de sharp qui a réussi à faire disparaître
sa maison sous l' enveloppe de son oeuvre
de céramistes avec un talent consommé
monsieur isidore manil assiettes cassées
rien ne lui a échappé et pas seulement les
murs et des planchers tout le mobilier a subi
les effets de son amour de l'art pour lequel
depuis 30 ans ils sacrifient allègrement la
vaisselle du ménage mais la noblesse d'une cause
ne justifie t'elle pas les plus grands sacrifices
les footballeurs du racing club de paris
maillot claire sont à l'image des joueurs
de l'équipe de france ils n'ont pas bien
digéré la technique du football moderne le
football est un jeu simple les joueurs de
nîmes leur en administre la fois le droit
au but c'est la devise des nîmois qui donne une
leçon parfois gênantes au parisien qui frise le
ridicule devant trente mille spectateurs
pas toujours très fiers de leur équipe
roger marche est sans doute le seul joueur
du racing a tenté quelque chose au moins
lui il ne s'embarrasse pas de fioritures ce
qui n'empêche pas les nîmois de continuer
leur petite exhibition bien simple est
bien nette et sans bavure on apprécie
en connaisseur dans les tribunes et
pendant ce temps sur le terrain les
nîmois ne s'arrête pas en si bon chemin
ils sont sans pitié pour le racing les
bus ajoute au but 3 0 et ce n'est pas fini
jugez en par les réactions des spectateurs
et à 0 pour terminer et c'est encore bon
marché du béton à la sortie du parc des princes
en soi c'est la devise de ces pilotes
allemands pour se faire respecter sur
la route il faut regarder les choses en
face et surtout garder son sang froid
avec ce système le problème du
croisement est facile à résoudre
ici la méthode n'est pas encore
tout à fait au point on peut être
encore mieux en définitive respecter le
code de la route c'est même plus sûres
il